tell me about something that you're
really grateful for I have a pretty darn
great cat he's got those positive male
influence in my life sometimes it's
tough spending so much time in the car
I'm from Boston and that's kind of a
known factor for road rage I get really
frustrated when I'm driving
[Music]
I love the thought of working on my
relationship goals with a life coach
while I'm driving how do you want women
to actually see you I want them to find
me interesting have quality things to
say and then what women to think I'm
attractive okay those are good things
that I see all three of those so that's
good the term life coach is so
intimidating to I can't escape I guess
where we're doing this tell me limit
about your goals
definitely patience a little more
empathy I guess - sir you ever need to
just go around this oh my god dude I
have some ideas bear with me here
mindfulness right I know one of the most
well researched strategies for actually
improving mindfulness is meditation I
always envied people that say they
meditate for 20 minutes a day I don't
know how they do it we're talking about
placing your attention in one place and
noticing if it wanders so even as you're
sitting here in the car very easily you
can say okay I'm just gonna really try
to keep my attention on my breath coming
and going top five things that you look
for in to me number one that we believe
the same ideals well I want someone
who's family-oriented someone who's
creative I really want someone atletic
and lastly I'd say someone who
spontaneous so the last three long-term
relationships that you've had how do
those girls fit into those five things
actually they don't fit at all they
didn't fit into your core things you're
looking for the relationships never
gonna work one of the things that you
could do is you put those five things
you know up here as a symbol on your car
so that when you're driving you can go
over it and you can actually read it be
super useful for me to think about and
chew on and meditate on my drive Siri
play Paradise Hills
you can think it's cheesy but I don't
know motion creates emotion right I'll
feel good music yeah you know you love
looking over to and seeing someone
grooving on their car oh yeah you know
you love it let's show the fans
Shaima class
I want you to start practicing
approaching women I always say talk to
yourself in your drive it's a perfect
time to practice what you're learning
and even practice talking to people you
know and listen to the way that you talk
those are things you can do in your car
as much as I love holding you hostage
right now yes what are some things that
I can do when I'm by myself where I
don't get to have you right at my
disposal one thing is the idea of
practicing gratitude so what I like to
do is think of three things - like
pretty significant things and one thing
that's like really small is here's the
thing if we're only super grateful for
like the big things in life we miss out
on the little things - so gratitude joy
or the Kryptonite for impatience that is
something that you can be doing on your
way to work in the car you don't need to
anybody else in the car with you to be
practicing gratitude so how did this
make your commute better well I haven't
remember the last time I've laughed on
my way to work and a waffle it took some
of the stress out of it and to try to
remember that not everything is the end
of the world that you can kind of just
take a moment to Center and to kind of
chill out a little bit I look happy
excited the energy is up have you
learned anything
the biggest piece I feel is the
confidence that I'm supposed to have
knowing that I have lots to offer a
woman you've showed me how to use my
time in the car to really let that sink
in you're a wonderful guy and they're
gonna make a wonderful boyfriend - some
lucky girl oh sweet - say thank you
[Music]